وجهات عربيه جاءت ضمن قائمه افضل القرى
السياحيه حول العالم لعام 2022 في المرتبه
21 تاتي مدينه العلا التراثيه السعوديه
التحفه المشهوره بمناظرها الخلابه
ومواقعها الاثريه العريقه التي تحفظ اسرار
200,000 عام من التاريخ الانساني في
المرتبه 18 تاتي مملكه المغرب عن طريق
قريه مولاي بوزاره الطون وهي قريه ساحليه
صغيره تقع في محافظه الصويره هي مقصد
لمحبي ركوب الامواج ومن المغرب ايضا تاتي
قريه الخربات في المرتبه السابعه عشره
عالميا والتي تتميز بقصرها الذي يعودوا
بنائه للقرون ويتمتعوا بجذبيه سياحيه يضم
ايضا
ورشه حرف تقليديه كذلك غرفا فندقيه وفي
المرتبه الرابعه اسرع عالميا قريه ام قيس
في الاردن التي كانت تعرف في السابق باسم
جداره تطل على وادي الاردن وبحيره طبريه
وتشتهر بشوارعها ذات الاعمده ومتاحفها
التي تضم تحفا من العصر الاسلاميه
والروماني اخيرا في المرتبه الحاديه عشر
عالميا قريه كفر كما الفلسطينيه هي قريه
شركسيه تقع في منطقه الجليل الاوسط اعد
تاسيسها في العهد العثماني ويعتقد ان
البلده كانت ماهوله بالسكان منذ القرن
السادس الميلادي